hello and welcome to this video playing
on my way here and it will be a scotch
game at try something else of my
checking variation in here he plays this
funky line by the way my rating has
dropped maybe I'll get two points back
the thing is I played them against the
cheetah and if you watch the game before
that you might already suspect then you
might already suspect that um let the
guy was doing something wrong ok anyway
I have to play this game now enter he
confuses me as usual mr. my way ok so my
plane normal moose and this is the kind
of thing actually after I played against
the cheetah I should just stop the
session because I'm so irritated by
those idiots that I usually play badly
afterwards but ok I want to I want to
get a complete session here to have a
day of video so I'm I'm continuing ok
the chat message from the cheating team
kept the ICC okay so see 5 mm yeah looks
like a good move but if I go let's go d
5 if it takes twice i have a ch3 that I
can take I don't see much of an
alternative here anyway maybe it just
goes Bishop f4 I am ok I can take c5
though
yeah see if I was attacked and if I get
to just go see 60 I should be okay piece
design but ok so what to do okay let's
go see 6 and see about this how to play
quincy aid as an idea gaining a tempo
and then Bishop f5 and 94 this is a text
my peer the seven activates my piece is
quite nicely no no that's not bad I can
also play a rook be 3g for progressive h
h 5 I mean okay not totally sure what is
continuation is now g5 i can i will just
go back I actually could have sacrificed
the exchange here that would have been
interesting rookie three and then Bishop
takes you five but this is an option
here I have to keep that in mind to give
the exchange now for big activity
I this is a slow player is a good player
but a slow player and yeah to e4 or not
night h7 there's g6 actually I have
Bishop f5 as an intermediate move this
is probably the right decision we should
have five Queenie too though it's not a
big deal i can move the night if you
take the h5 i take me to ok so this is a
good good move I guess yeah yeah okay
that looks good and now probably just 94
m yeah this is good asking why do I he
has so many square weaknesses yeah I'm
happy this looks good
okay this is a temple and now how to how
to do this since they are there many
very active possibilities here that look
tempting maybe this is just good and
simple move but a good move intending to
take the spawn or I mean queen bee ADA
between be a pushover for would be to
and preventing be form and also
threatening to just take the bishop it's
difficult for him to find something
decent here if I go to d3 okay it's not
not clear that this helps but okay if I
check its bishops till the sugar for it
looks like I should win material him it
really does maybe this Center couldn't
be 8 i'm really not sure check then rook
takes be to next I just wanted to not
think any longer
rook takes be too if you moves the Queen
I have Bishop takes h3 okay so not this
time let's see ok I think I have to take
any way here Bishop before is a is a
good continuation but we'll see where he
goes where's he going Bishop c5 is also
bishops if I are taking the pond it's
also probably good in some cases Bishop
pepper should be for now is that you
will return the exchange I guess which
is not completely great no but still do
I have something better probably not so
let's put it down rookie form no not
going forward for this hmm ok so look C
2 y is for Bishop c5
I ok yeah it's how to not trade here
right time morning yeah oh I wanted to
play Bishop f2 but this isn't actually
doing anything good damn ok check he
will actually get this I came and now
that was bad I spoiled my winning
position him check man i really hate it
was such a good game actually i really
really played it ok i mean it was a good
game heart hurt I can't rap I heard and
how he wants to win know what check I'm
not doing this twice now I'm really hard
time ha ha and I come on this is crazy
you cannot decline and then offer again
and what not this is this is not going
to work like for this time now i'm not
i'm offering once and if it doesn't take
it yeah
I cannot cannot do much more and the
position was like a total win right here
I just did not find find the win I can
just take h three year Wow why is this
and check then taking okay I should f4
look be too huh Wow nope yeah there
there must have been a couple of times
and this also looks great but it doesn't
doesn't seem to win it didn't even he
didn't give the exchange back I was cool
and so what now Queen B 5 and 2 minus a
million okay and it just looks it looks
very bad now and this is this is not not
that great Jack maybe it's a draw it's
this is not not what so what what should
have happened now we just click click
click and whatever the result um yeah
whatever was the result it doesn't
really matter this is known increment
blitz yeah I should have won this game
like round wrong move 25 but I didn't
didn't manage okay well thanks for
watching